صافرات الإنذار ترتفع
في دونيتسك،
الرئيس الأوكراني يرتدي بزته العسكرية
ودرعه وخوذته
ويستعد لكابوس حرب
يأمل أن يصحو منه سريعا
وقبل فوات الآوان ويقول
ما فائدة العقوبات إن بدأ الغزو وتم احتلال بلاده،
لابد من خطوة رادعة من واشنطن لموسكو
والراقصات الأوكرانيات
يرمين أزياء الرقص ويلبسن البزاة العسكرية،
ونساء أوكرانيا
يتدربن على اطلاق النار والاشتباكات،
و الرئيس الأمريكي جو بايدن
يعلم بالغزو الروسي لأوكرانيا
ولكنه لن يتصل ببوتين حسب قوله ..
الأطفال تقف أحلامهم  على أبواب مدارسهم،
مئات الآلاف يفرون من ديارهم،
كل ذلك إعلان بسيط لبدء كارثة خطيرة.
القصف متواصل بلا انقطاع
على المناطق الانفصالية،
أما رئيس جمهورية دونيتسك الانفصالية
فيعلن النفير، ويقول:
من يقدر على حمل السلاح فلينضم إلينا،
فنحن في أكثر الأوضاع جدية حتى الآن،
والحال أن روسيا تحشد الحشود العسكرية
من السلاح والعتاد والجنود
على الحدود الأوكرانية،،،،
فتقابلها أمريكا وأوروبا بإرسال تعزيزات
إلى أوكرانيا، وفي الوقت الذي خرج فيه
بايدن يعلنها صراحة،
أن بوتين سيغزو أوكرانيا...
يرد بوتين ويتهم الغرب بعدم الجدية
في عدم الضمانات الأمنية..
هي المرة الأولى التي تقوم روسيا فيها
بالتهديد المباشر
(إما أن توافقوا على مطالبنا
أو فالحرب خيار سهل لدينا)
وتضيف موسكو: تعتبر قواتنا الآن
منسحبة فهي داخل أراضينا وفي حدودنا،
وليس لأحد في العالم أي سلطة على روسيا،
ما دامت قواتها داخل حدود أراضيها...
الأمريكان يؤكدون أن روسيا
تريد غزو أوكرانيا، وأنها تحشد لذلك
منذ فترة بعيدة، والدليل ما حدث في  شبه جزيرة القرم
قبل ٧ أعوام عندما تم ضمها لموسكو عنوة،
والروس يردون أن أمريكا تريد من أوكرانيا
غزو المناطق الانفصالية،
ما يعني أن واشنطن تدفع بأوكرانيا لحرب
ضد روسيا.......
كل ذلك والأزمة الروسية الأوكرانية
لازالت بحاجة نتائج للحلول الديبلوماسية المقترحة،
والتي مازالت ضعيفة ولم تخرج للنور بعد، ...
جميع الآراء والتقارير تقول إن الحرب
أقرب من السلم، برغم رفض الجميع
أساسا لفكرة الحرب هذه،
فكيف سيكون الحال
خلال الأيام القليلة المقبلة؟
(وضع حكومة كييف)
تصفيق حار لأوكرانيا في مؤتمر ميونخ للأمن،
لم يقتنع الرئيس الأوكراني بالدعم الغربي،
وقال: (
الغرب قالوا أنهم سينفذون عقوبات على روسيا
إذا قامت بالغزو، إذا ما الذي تنتظرونه،
فلسنا بحاحة إلى العقوبات بعد الغزو،
فجزأ من بلدنا سيحتل واقتصادنا سيدمر،)
...وسط انتقادات مبطنة من كييف
لبعض الدول الغربية التي تقف عائقا
أمام انضمامها للناتو،
حيث وصف زيلينسكي موقع بلاده بأنها
(ليست مع أوروبا ولا مع روسيا)
وطالب وزير خارجية أوكرانيا
بفرض جزء من العقوبات
التي أعدت ضد روسيا لإيقافها الآن..
،كييف في موقف لا تحسد عليه،
فهي ترى أن الدعم الغربي لا يكفي
لردع روسيا وأمريكا تقول أن
قواتها دفاعية لا هجومية،
ليتوجب على رئيس الاوكراني
أن يجري لقاء مع بوتين، لمعرفة طلباته....
(وضع سكان الحدود)
عشرات المنازل تضررت في القرى الحدودية،
والسكان يقضون وقتا صعبا هناك،
وانقطاع في الغاز والكهرباء عن المنازل،
والناس يبيتون لياليهم في البرد القارص،
ولسان حالهم يقول
(أوقفوا الحرب لا يمكننا العيش على هذا النحو)
بينما يفضل البعض  الاختباء في الأقبية
خوفا من القصف المتواصل،
رافضين ترك بيوتهم وممتلكاتهم،
والتي تعني كل شيء بالنسبة لهم..
يقول السكان
(أين يجب أن نذهب، وإذا غادرنا جميعا
فمن سيستقبلنا، فهل قضينا حياتنا هنا
من أجل لا شيء،)..
ألا ينذر هذا بكارثة إنسانية
إذا ما اشتعلت الحرب في تلك المناطق؟...
هنا خرجت المظاهرات في مدينة لفيف الأوكرانية،
للتنديد بأعمال روسيا العدائية،
وداعية لوحدة ضرورية من كل الشركاء،
المتظاهرون يقولون أنهم ليسوا خائفين من الحرب،
ولكنهم يرفضون العيش تحت تهديدات روسيا
كونهم يعيشون خوفا لا يجعل النوم يسكن أعينهم،
مع لافتات تطالب الحكومة
بالمواجهة أو الاستسلام،،
هذه المدينة هي إحدى المدن التي بدأت
ترسل المتطوعين إلى الجبهة،
هم يطالبون الغرب ألا يجنحوا لمزاعم روسيا
بأنها لا تريد الحرب،
فروسيا تحاربهم منذ ٨ سنوات
لأنها ترفض الديمقراطية أساسا...
(تحرك أمريكي)
قذائف أوكرانية تسقط في الأراضي الروسية..
والرئيس الأمريكي يقول (إحساسي)
أن روسيا ستغزو أوكرانيا في الأيام القليلة المقبلة،....
بانتظار جلسة في واشنطن لمجلس الأمن
يشرف عليها جو بايدن،
وستناقش الجلسة
( معلومات حصلت عليها واشنطن
بأن بوتين قد أمر ببدء هجوم واسع النطاق على أوكرانيا)
ووزير الخارجية الأمريكي بلينكن
يؤكد أن روسيا على أعتاب غزو أوكرانيا..
مشيرا لاستعداد الرئيس جو بايدن
للتحدث مع الرئيس الروسي في أي وقت
وبأي صيغة،،
وملوحا بإتمام أمريكا لإعداد حزمة ضخمة
من العقوبات على روسيا إذا غزت أوكرانيا..
وسط قلق من تمديد المناورات الروسية البيلاروسية...
فهل تتوقف الأزمة عند ذلك أم أن لروسيا رأي آخر؟